مساء الخير اذا كان حضرتك ممن يحتفلون
بعيد الحب نقول لحضرتك كل سنه وانت طيب
واذا ما كنتش بتحتفل بعيد الحب اللي مش
حدش عارف اصله ولا جذوره بشكل واضح ولا
مين هو اساسا القديس فالنتاين اللي الناس
بتحتفل بيه من مئات السنين نقول لحضرتك ان
موضوع النهارده مش عن عيد الحب ولا عن
الفالنتاين ولكن عن الدب اللي بيتقدم كهد
في كل انحاء العالم تعبير عن الحب ازاي
الدب الحيوان المفترس تحول في غفله من
الزمن الى اشهر هديه بتقدم او بيتباها
العشاق من تحديدا من الرجال الى النساء
فضلا طبعا على انه واحد من اهم الهدايا
اللي بيقدمها كل الاباء
لاولادهم المفروض ان الدب ده حيوان مفترس
ازاي تحول الى هديه لطيفه وجميله للعشاق
وللاطفال الحقيقه دي ليها قصه تستحق ان
احنا نحكيها وبترجع جذورها لحوالي 115 سنه
والصدفه وحدها كانت وراها في سنه
1902 وتحديدا في نوفمبر من العام ده
الرئيس الامريكي ثيودور
روزفيلد اللي كان معروف الناس بيسموه تيدي
يعني تيدي روزفيلد كان في رحله صيد في
الغابات مع مجموعه من اصدقائه اللي تمكنوا
من اصطياد ضب اسود كبير و يعني
ا اسخنه جراحا يعني عملوا فيه جراح
وبهدلوا الدب جدا وربطوه في شجره وطلبوا
من الرئيس اللي كان في مكان اني ان يجي
ويجهز عليه برصاصه لكن الرئيس قال انا
صحيح بحب الصيد لكن مش شايف ان شيء اتباهى
به ولا افخر به ان انا اقتل دب مربوط في
شجره صحيح انه لاحقا قرر انه يقتل الدب بس
لسبب اخر مش انه يتباهى بقتله ولكن على
عشان يرحمه من العذاب اللي بيشعر بيه
نتيجه الاصابات اللي لحقت بيه اليوم
التالي مباشره كانت جريده واشنطن بوست من
شها الرئيسي تيدي روزفلت او تيدي يرفض قتل
دب مربوط على شجره وبعدها والقصه طبعا
اثارت جدل وبعدها على طول في كاريك رسام
كاريكاتير في صحيفه اصغر شويه اسمها واشن
واشنطن ستار رسم الرئيس والدب وبس كان
لهدف ثاني خالص انه يصور الرئيس على انه
راجل دايما متردد لكن في نفس الوقت كان في
شركه العاب يملكها شخص اسمه مورس ميتشوم
ومعا شريكه اسمها روز فكروا في قصه ثانيه
او في ملمح ثاني ليه ما نحول الدب اللي
بقى كرتون ده عليه جدل الى لعبه ولعبه
تحمل اسم الرئيس بالفعل صمم لعبه وبعدين
عشان تسمي لعبه جديده اللي هي دب في شكل
يعني لعبه اطفال فكره كانت جريئه توقع ان
ممكن تنجح الى حد ما بس ما توقعتش تنجح
بالشكل ده وطلب انه من الرئيس اذن لان هذا
ما يجب ان يتم وبعت للبيت الابيض والرئيس
الامريكي وافق وفعلا سمى الدب تيدي بير
بير يعني دب وتيدي ده اسم الرئيس الامريكي
والناس كلهم عارفين ان اللعبه اللي احنا
بنمسكها في ايدينا النهارده بنقول عليها
بالانجليزي تيدي
بير الدب سرعان ما نجح بشكل ما حدش متوقعه
لا الرئيس اللي وافق ان يمنحه اسمه ولا
شركه الالعاب اللي وجدت نفسها
بتصنع بتنتج كميات ضخمه جدا وكونوا شركه
بقى منتجها الرئيسي هو الدببه والحقيقه
اللعبه انتشرت جدا الى درجه ان هي حلت محل
العرايس اللي كانت دايما بيمسكوها البنات
الصغيرين وهم اطفال لدرجه ان عضو كونجرس
قال بعدها كم بكم سنه انا خايف من انتشار
الدببه دي انها تقتل غرائز الامومه عند
بناتنا اللعبه انتشرت جدا وتحولت الى
الهديه رقم واحد من الاباء الى الاطفال
وتحولت بالتالي الى الهديه رقم واحد ا
لبين العشاق في عيد الحب لانه التدي بير
تحول الى رمز للطفوله ورمز للحب ورمز لما
حد بيديه لبنت معناها انه بيحبها وحابب
انه يتجوزوا او يرتبطوا ويكون بينهم اطفال
و وبالشكل ده اتولدت الفكره الغريبه دي ان
الدب المفترس يتحول الى رمز للحب شكرا
جزيلا وكل سنه وانتم طيبين